after coming under fire for the
haphazard u.s evacuation from
afghanistan the biden administration is
facing new criticism for a botched drone
attack several weeks ago that killed
innocent civilians there yesterday the
pentagon admitted that it made what it
said was quote a tragic mistake
believing it was targeting terrorists
threatening american troops at the kabul
airport christina raffini is at the
white house christina good morning
good morning michelle that's right what
the pentagon initially said was a
righteous strike targeting a terrorist
looking to do harm against civilians and
american forces they now admit was
anything but
this security video shows an afghan aid
worker loading a car with jugs of water
jugs the u.s military now says it
mistook for explosives we now assess
that it is unlikely that the vehicle and
those who died were associated with isis
k or were a direct threat to u.s forces
after tracking zamariamati's car around
kabul for eight hours military drones
saw the vehicle pull into a compound
near the kabul airport fearing another
deadly attack like the one that killed
13 american service members just days
before the drone fired
[Applause]
igniting a nearby propane tank that
caused a secondary explosion i am now
convinced that as many as 10 civilians
including up to seven children were
tragically killed in that strike
the deadly mistake punctuated the u.s
military's messy and chaotic withdrawal
from afghanistan a withdrawal that left
about a hundred american citizens and
possibly thousands of afghan translators
and allies behind can you guarantee to
this committee that we will get them out
going forward we continue to look to
them yesterday after weeks of stalemate
a charter flight left mazary sharif in
northern afghanistan where lawmakers and
aid groups say the taliban has been
preventing planes from taking off the
flight landed in doha and included
american citizens permanent residents
and afghans
now one of the reasons the biden
administration said it wanted to leave
afghanistan was to focus on other
strategic priorities like countering
china to that end this week the united
states said it was going to sell
nuclear-powered submarines to the
australians problem is nobody told the
french who had a 360 billion sorry
excuse me 36
36 billion dollar contract to build
regular submarines a contract that was
summarily cancelled now the french are
as they say trey trey facet or very
angry and have recalled their
ambassadors both to the united states
and to australia dana
all right christina thank you the